what's going on guys this is rob and we
are here with the second son of asgard
storyline which is basically the
aftermath to like the death of odin uh
and as always when it comes to donnie
kate's there's just this massive reveal
at the end of all this uh but here's one
of the really really cool things that i
like about this donnie kate's focus is
pretty heavily on the legacy of odin
especially in relation to thor and in
fact it's it's this this kind of
realization that thor has about odin
that he had never really considered
before and so the way this opens up is
it really kind of brings in the idea
that like the like the the fall of odin
has officially happened now there is
something to understand here donnie
kate's treats this with a kind of
finality that we haven't necessarily
seen before because it's not the first
time that odin has died and probably the
most notable time when that happened was
during dan jurgen's run on thor back in
the 90s uh when you basically had the
death of odin during the fight with
certain and that was a way to kind of
remove odin from the landscape and then
half thor end up becoming king we
basically got stories where he was just
a terrible king and then ultimately that
went into thor ragnarok or thor
disassembled right like his death and
everything that was part of like the
lead up to house of m and civil war and
avengers disassembled and all that kind
of stuff right that whole reshuffling of
marvel under uh under joe quesada and
brian michael bendis uh and the reason
why i say there's a kind of finality
here that you didn't necessarily see
before is because one the body of odin
of course is being taken through asgard
but two everyone's here and when i say
everyone i mean everyone right like the
celestials the watcher silver surfer uh
like the frost giants the fantastic four
guardians of the galaxy i mean
everyone's here and this is really
really cool because this is really
donnie kate's way of just kind of
highlighting the legacy of odin right
that like odin is a figure and it's one
of those funny things because nine times
out of ten when you think of own you
think of just an old guy who hangs out
in asgard while his family goes and does
stuff right like thor goes and fights on
the avengers you know uh in more recent
years with jason aaron who really in the
last year or so he's focused on like
avengers bc so the fact that odin is
actually was or at least was at one
point in time an active member of the
superhero community but you don't really
think of odin as a guy that comes into
contact with these people but the funny
thing is that over the course of his
publication history in marvel he's come
in contact with all of them some you
know at some point along the line but
more so than that the role of odin is
really what people are here remembering
as much as odin himself he was the all
father of asgard one of the most
powerful beings in the marvel universe
certainly not somebody you scoff over
now the funny thing is you don't
actually see uh galactus here as far as
i can tell and that makes sense because
odin headbutted the hell out of galactus
and basically fractured his helmet and
that probably pissed him off a little
bit like i imagine galactus still
probably holds a little grudge you know
like silver servers like hey galactus
we're all going to the funeral for for
odin are you going to come along and
galaxy's like nah man that guy was a
dick
i have no clue if that's going to be the
case if that's that's the case or not
but i'd like to believe that it is but
nonetheless while odin's not as powerful
as the celestials the fact is like he's
had dealings with the celestials right
the third celestial host when they told
the gods to basically stay off
humanity's evolution right just
different things along those lines so
again it's kind of a cool thing but what
thor says here and this is what's so
cool what the worst says here is odin
was a troubled man a vicious god a great
and unyielding king a complicated
husband and a great shadow that falls
ever still on my brother and i and it's
kind of funny he says the old bastard is
a ghost now and i'm still terrified of
him and he says the truth is my father
pushed me to the brink of madness more
times than i can count he was a man of
great and terrible contradictions here
was the great conquering odin a king
with a crown of blood feared by all with
mercy for none and yet here is odin
carrying and raising his greatest
enemies abandoned child as if it were
his own of course referencing loki and
he says granting power to those in need
those he would judge as equals though
their blood ran not of asgard judging
them by the worthiness only he seemed to
see in their hearts a trait he seemed so
very seldomly to find in me now here's
the thing the relationship between odin
and thor is a very complicated
relationship and that's what thor says
here he says i do not say here today
anything you all have not heard before
hell my father has cast me out of his
kingdoms more times than i can count and
every damn time i would rage scream and
curse his name at a silent sky and each
and every damn time i would return a
better man a better god so that in time
i would be a better king to you to all
of you now this is particularly
important here because thor is
referencing both of course when he was
cast out and you you know had the
memories of donald blake and all that
kind of stuff happen but what he's also
talking about here is odin breaking the
cycle of ragnarok now if those of you
guys who don't really know that mythos
right you don't really know about the
the cycle of ragnarok being broken by
odin in terms of thor being sent to
earth it was kind of this hidden reason
why it was that thor was sent to earth
in the form of donald blake or you know
kind of taking on the form of donald
blake and that kind of thing that over
time in marvel comics so when they when
we got the original ragnarok story what
they explained is that that cycle had
happened over and over and over again
that presumably it always happens with
like the collapse of the universe that
whenever a universe collapses or is
somehow destroyed asgard would be
destroyed and then would ultimately come
back and that seemingly the ones who sit
above and shadow these kind of
mysterious entities up there which as
far as we know the only real standard
that we have in terms of what they were
was loki potentially referring to them
as like beyonders and like that was it
and even then it was just a guess right
he's like maybe they are we don't really
know who the ones who sit above and
shadow are that they would feed on the
energy of the asgardians when they were
destroyed so perhaps the cycle of
ragnarok would happen multiple times
over the course of the lifespan of a
singular universe but whatever it is
odin had eventually come to this
realization that the cycle of ragnarok
uh basically pervaded right that it
persisted that the cycle of ragnarok
always happened that the the asgardians
were always destroyed when asgard was
basically annihilated and it would
always come back in some form or fashion
and that the ones who sit above in
shadow would feed on that energy and so
in order to break that cycle of ragnarok
instead of thor just being the son of
odin who would exist you know out in
asgard and would have these crazy
adventures and stuff like that he cast
him out now the other part of it was
also because thor was a dick right he
needed to learn a lesson right he was he
was really really arrogant full of
hubris and he had to be brought down a
few pegs but the other thing was sending
him to earth would basically create a
bond between thor and humanity and in
fact bring thor to a level of empathy
and understanding and patience that he
wouldn't have readily had and so as a
result of that thor ended up coming back
and he was the one that broke the cycle
of ragnarok and odin knew that he
wouldn't be able to be the one to do it
because his path was leading him
inexorably to certain right remember
like the whole prophecy of uh of
ragnarok was that odin would die at the
hands of certain so he knew he wouldn't
live long enough to actually stop the
cycle that was his fate and so it's a
really really interesting thing because
what's kind of funny about that is carl
young had a really good quote i'm kind
of paraphrasing here when i say it but
basically if you never learn to control
your your subconscious it will control
your conscious mind and you will call it
fate and so just this really really
interesting thing right that like
perhaps in that idea and that that that
just hell-bent belief on that prophecy
odin was actually solidifying his own
destiny right that it never really
existed in any concrete form until he
made it true so and even a little little
kind of uh explanation there which i
think is pretty important when it comes
to the mythos but what thor also reveals
here and this is really really awesome
he reveals something called the book of
kings and he says the way he knows all
this that it wasn't just odin being hard
on him for the sake of being hard on him
that it was odin being hard on him in
order to ensure that thor would become a
capable king as he said only the king of
asgard may read the hidden pages of the
book of kings that enchantment has been
the law in the letter since the days of
titans since the days of bury our first
king of boer my grandfather to our
father odin the second son of asgard and
now to me and so what this is where you
kind of transition into some of those
smaller stories ah they're not overly
important again it's kind of like the
origin of beta ray bill basically being
retold and the first fight between thor
and the man gog and different things
along those lines right it's just a cool
little tidbit here now what comes once
we jump back to kind of the main set of
events themselves is basically the the
funeral process or the kind of funeral
pyre for odin now one of the things to
know as far as i understand i'm not
going to swear by this because i'm not
necessarily a historian but as i
understand it one of the more common
methods of burial uh for those
individuals who follow the norse
mythological belief system was actually
burial with grave goods and the reason
why is because what that would do is the
goods themselves would basically match
the social standing of the individual
who had perished so that when they
traveled to the afterlife they would
maintain that social standing now that
would also include things like burying
them with a loved one or somebody who
basically worked directly for them or
operated under them like a like a horse
thrall or something along those lines i
mean there were different ways in which
it was done for this case with odin and
the fact that in norse mythology
cremation was also also a concept that's
how this burial process happens here
that odin's body is effectively supposed
to be burned and so what ends up
happening is that as odin had decreed as
he had asked right the way the way it's
given to us is it said the arrow that
volstead carries weighs heavy in his
hands though in fact it weighs nothing
at all the shaft of the arrow was
fashioned from gun gear the odin spear
the spear of heaven it had been called
though it carries many darker names in
certain realms though perhaps the saying
was merely prophecy as now the arrow
that was the odin spear will be guided
on its journey by flights made of
angel's wings the bow was a gift as well
a branch from idrissil the world ash the
avenger hawkeye carved the longbow
himself making sure its flight would be
strong and true the bose string was
woven from the abyss black hair of hella
goddess of death a gift or perhaps a
threat from niflheim whatever the
message is thor cares not the arrow's
head made of the eternal flame of
muspelheim and a fix to the spear with
sap from the world tree burns as deep as
hell itself in his hands and so what was
basically supposed to happen here is
thor himself would fire the arrow off at
the funeral pyre of odin and in turn
odin's funeral pyre of course would be
set alight and odin would essentially
experience the the the kind of funeral
that he had requested and that is
customary for him the problem with this
is thor says i can't right and he
actually passes it off to loki and in
turn loki's like no you're the firstborn
and the heir to the throne this is your
responsibility and ultimately the
response of loki is it's a king's decree
that his heir ignite the pyre thor and
thor's response is yes and i am a king
loki you have to do this for me and
ultimately loki fires off the shot which
of course ignites the funeral pyre of
of odin and he basically becomes a kind
of burning light out there in the in the
sky of asgard essentially to live
forever the reason why this matters is
because following that you transition to
the aftermath of all of this and you
basically get the voice of odin as it
communicates with thor now as a bit of
follow up here for people who are just
now joining us one i highly suggest that
you go watch the last video series that
we did we'll have the playlist down in
the description you'll be able to see
the whole thing but in effect it
basically saw the hammer of mjolnir
being destroyed and then ultimately
being reforged but where the hammer had
previously contained what was in effect
a cosmic entity once the cosmic entity
was defeated that angela the sister of
thor and one of the angels of heaven had
basically had the hammer rebuilt but
inside the hammer was the spirit of odin
what we didn't know was why odin's
spirit was inside the hammer itself and
so ultimately the spirit of odin
literally just kind of communicates with
thor and kind of taunts him in the same
way it always had right like i thought i
taught you how to shoot having your
little brother do the deed good god man
like how are you expected to run asgard
if you can't even perform the dying wish
of a king and of course thor's like no
right he's tired of hearing the voice of
his father and of course like the
response of owners i'm sorry i couldn't
attend i couldn't bear to see your
mother suffer and of course as thor
continues to yell out and he's like
raise your voice to me one more time and
we'll see who wields this hammer and
thor asks like why are you here right
like once he smashes the hammer against
uh against the emir he's like why are
you here answer me like you've made me
carry your weight my entire life and now
i have to carry your weight even after
you're dead right like why are you here
you should be in valhalla you should be
in the afterlife at the very least you
should be leaving me the hell alone
because the response of odin is like you
know you're king and and like you have
to do this and ultimately the response
of thor is like now i'm king right like
where were you when the black winter
came for asgard and the black winter had
basically almost threatened to destroy
everything when galactus came crashing
down into asgard itself and threatened
to consume it where were you during the
events of like the war of realms when
when your wife needed you right in all
these times and all these experiences
when your family needed you to be there
and you were just this cold unanswering
person where were you doing during all
of that right and then now i'm supposed
to need your guidance now i'm supposed
to need you and again it's one of these
things where thor holds on to a lot of
anger and a lot of resentment towards
odin and so he's like why won't you just
leave me alone right why won't you just
let me lose you and the response of odin
is because i can't i can't go home thor
i cannot go to valhalla and he says i
tried when my spirit passed i walked to
the gates of valhalla to find my
brothers and my father but the problem
is someone had smashed open the gates of
valhalla and when i got there the halls
were empty not a single soul remained
and he's like i'm here because i need
you because i have nowhere else to go
he's like valhalla is completely gone
now here's the question you have to ask
who in the heck did this because there
is a ton of stuff like there's a lot of
power in the halls of valhalla one it's
every every just incredibly honorable
warrior that's ever fought right like
the bravest of people in the afterlife
exist in valhalla just imagine an army
of thor's or an army of odin's they all
exist in valhalla then you have the
valkyrie right so it means whoever did
this has to be a being of an incredible
level of power in order to pull this off
no clue who it could have been but it's
donnie kate's which has me excited
i just kind of hope it's not the return
of gore but with that being said guys
we're going to bring this to an end uh
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace